this was a fixture between Hollywood
royalty and actual royalty the king and
queen consort at the glitzius club in
the Panorama League wrexham the North
Wales town that actors Ryan Reynolds and
Rob mcelhenney have really bought into a
town that's now become a city
we'll do anything to uplift and and
Elevate this community in this club and
having the king pay a visitors uh is
certainly one way to do it it's our
first team manager Phil Parkinson
yes
as they toured the area there was no
mention of the Harry and Megan Netflix
series that emerged from Hollywood this
week
I've not seen it in my own never heard
of it you don't know well
but plenty here have seen it and had
some advice
they love you know your mom wouldn't
want this be friends
we don't know
the ins and outs
and
hopefully and pray that they do all come
together whatever discussions are going
on with the palace about how best to
respond to the Netflix series those
decisions won't be rushed this visit
celebrating wrexham City status was
simply the king and queen consort
getting on with the job
a church service celebrated wrexham's
elevation a little earlier today I had
the opportunity to see one of the other
wonders of Rickson namely the football
club
which is busy putting rexen on the map
as never before
now the Royals are sticking to Safe
ground but with more episodes from Harry
and Megan to come ignoring the
accusations may only get harder
Lisa Dowd Sky News wrexham